Can I can I raise a point?
Go ahead.
Okay. So, I I heard you saying that
about the angel of the Lord that they
when it says in Exodus, I think 23, it's
it speaks about when God said, "I'll
send the angel before you, right?"
Okay.
Okay. So, you were saying that that the
name of God is within him.
So, that means he's part of the God,
right?
No, it says it explains why he can
forgive sins because my name is in him.
What's the connection in forgiving sins
and my name is in him?
Right. So, so what I don't understand.
So, what are you trying to say? God's
name is within him means what? Because
God is saying the reason why he can do
what only God can do, forgive sins, is
my name is in him. So, what does it mean
that he has the name? I'm not saying he
came in the name. My name is in him.
Now, can you show me where God says that
of any prophet, my name is in that
prophet? Yes, I can show you that God
says that he will dwell within all the
nation.
So, he God himself will dwell inside all
the nation.
>> with that.
What I'm asking you is, show me. I
believe God dwells in the midst of us
and in us. You're you're talking to a
Christian.
We believe we're the temple of God and
God's spirit is in us. I'm asking you,
show me where God says, "My name is in
Moses. My name is in Isaiah, which is
why they forgive sins."
Right. So, no, my question is to me it
would seem that God himself dwelling
within us is greater than God's name,
right? God himself is greater than the
name itself.
No, because God dwelling in you is like
God dwelling in the temple. The temple
is not God, but he can then fill it with
his presence.
The name of God represents his power,
authority, and ability because the
explanation is there.
He will not forgive your sins for my
name is in him. So, if God is in you, do
you can then forgive sins?
Okay. So, I do know that in the New
Testament
the the disciples were able to forgive
sins. No, brother, that's not going to
help your case because I'm going to tell
you how they did it. They proclaim
forgiveness in the name of Jesus.
Brother, you're going to quote New
Testament? Let me show you how. Right.
No, so I'm just What?
I No, that didn't help your case. When
Jesus says, "Whoever sins you forgive is
are going to go and say, 'Repent and be
baptized in the name of Jesus and you'll
be forgiven.'" But, if you don't repent
and believe, you will be condemned.
That's the context of John 10 20:23.
Brother, I know the New Testament.
Put that aside for a minute. I'll come
there. See, I want to answer all your
texts.
Do you see in Exodus 23:21
that God is explaining why the angel can
forgive sins?
Yeah, yeah, so I see that point. The
thing is that you can see in the chapter
Exodus chapter 32 sins besides God. And
you know that the same word for forgive
your transgressions is used in Genesis
Joshua 24:19, right?
Same word in Joshua
Let me see 20 Joshua 24. Let me check.
What did you say there?
It uses the same word, "Pardon your
transgressions." And who does it there?
Let me open up and see.
Uh which verse?
Verse 19, Joshua 24:19.
Okay, so it says Joshua says to the
nation
you can't worship God because he's holy.
He's
He won't forgive your sins.
If you look at the phrase "pardon your
transgression" Exodus 23:21, it's the
same used in Joshua 24:19.
Yeah, I see.
See it again?
Yeah, I see. So, who forgives sins in
Joshua 24:19?
I got to say he wouldn't means he has
ability to Yes, I see what you're
saying. But, wait. Why is it then in
Exodus 23:21 it's the angel who does
what God does?
Yeah, so I would say that God gave him
the ability to do so because you can see
that that angel is not God. They have
proof of that that you can see in
chapter Be patient. I'll give it to you.
He didn't say he gave him the ability.
You lied. It says, "My name is Adonai."
Didn't say he gave it to him. What does
No, it doesn't say.
What does it say it was given to him?
Right, it does not say. I agree with
you. But, why do I believe so? I have a
a proof of that.
>> Okay, let me I'll let you give your
proof. Let me take a step back.
Okay. So, do you admit that what God
said about the angel, he will not
forgive your sins, it's the exact same
thing Joshua said about God in Joshua
24:19?
Yeah.
Now, I'm going to ask you another
question. Why is the
the word kadosh plural, kadoshim?
Yes, so that goes back to the plural
plurality
talking to God in plurality. I would say
it's because of how you say I forgot
that name. Like call honor, like It
won't work here. You know why? Why? You
just admitted to everyone the angel and
God both forgive sins.
You just admitted it.
That's why it's kadoshim plural because
it's not one person who's the God that
forgives. It's God and his angel. What
are you not following? Yeah, yeah, but I
I don't see how you limit it to three
persons in the God in the Old Testament.
If you want to say all these are God,
you can get to ten.
>> fine. Let's say that's fine. Do you now
admit your Old Testament Tanakh does not
teach God as one person?
Even if it's five.
According to what you showed me till
now, yes. But, I have some responses to
this. So, I'll I'll let you respond.
>> Okay. But, you bring the first I got to
deal Just I was going to do with the
wisdom Proverbs 8, but you changed the
subject. Now, one more example that you
the angel forgives sins, open up
Zechariah chapter 3.
And you can bring your objection. I'm
not running from it, but I got to deal
with your points. I'm jumping with you.
Okay. Zechariah 3:1-2.
Let me pull it up.
Read.
>> All right. Now it's Zechariah
2. If you open it up, I'm going to bring
the English so people can see it.
Yeah. Zechariah 3.
All right.
1 and 2. Then verse 1, you see and out
of respect for you cuz I don't want you
to think I'm a jerk. I don't cuz I want
you to come to know the true God and
your Messiah.
Believe it or not, I do love you.
I may be tough, but I love you because
Jesus did you makes me love you even
though you think he's a curse and
burning and boiling Let's put that
aside.
I want you to see in Zechariah 3 it
says, "Then he showed me Joshua the high
priest standing before the angel of
Hash- Hashem." We'll say Hashem, right?
Yeah. And Satan standing at his right
hand to accuse him. Now, if you notice
in verse 3,
there are only three mentioned.
The high priest,
the angel of Hashem, and Sat- Satan,
right? Satan ha Satan, right?
>> Yeah.
Okay.
In verse 2, who rebukes who?
Let me see.
Hashem said God God rebukes.
No, but read it again. It says,
"Hashem said to ha Satan, Hashem rebuke
you."
Correct.
Who's the Hashem that so told Satan,
"Hashem rebuke you"?
God. The the the father God. No, verse 2
told you who was there.
Verse 1. Why did you change it? Right.
So, if you see
if you see verse 1, you see someone
showed Joshua that vision, right? Who
showed him that vision? God. So, God is
in the picture already.
>> no, no. If you read Zechariah, the angel
on earth showed him.
If you read Zechariah 1 and 2 and 3,
there's an angel [clears throat] on
earth accompanying Zechariah. No, it's
not God.
>> Can you show me which verse? I'm not
aware. Brother, start that chapter. We
want to go from chapter 1 we read to 3
you're going to see an angel came and
spoke to him. It's in chapter 1, read
it. The angel between the Myrtle trees
that looked like a man. And then it goes
to chapter 2 and 3.
Okay, so you're saying that the
So, you're saying that the angel showed
this vision to Joshua? There's an angel
on earth that Zachariah is talking to.
Chapter 1, chapter 2, chapter 3. It's
not me, I'm not making up. You go to
Zachariah 1, you'll see. He sees angels
and he sees a man, an angel
who's in the Myrtle trees. It's there.
Open up one, you'll glance through it.
In chapter 2, you'll glance through it.
And then you're going to go to chapter
3. Right, so you just reminded me that
in chapter 1, I'm reading it here in
verse 12. The angel that you're
referring to. No, no, no, it's the same
chapter. Just that you said that there's
an angel. So, I see here the angel asks
God
till when you won't have mercy on
Jerusalem.
>> That doesn't help your case. You
understand?
>> he asking if he's got if he knows
everything? Why is he asking that?
>> not asking. It's like when God tells
Cain, "Where is your brother?" Or when
God tells Adam, "Where are you?" You
know this better than me. That shows you
the power of the intercession of the
angel because if you read it carefully,
it's not the angel that's asking, "How
long?" Meaning, "Enough is enough."
Because once he prayed, God showed mercy
towards Jerusalem. It was the angel's
intercession that moved God to stop
punishing Jerusalem. Read your context,
12 to 14, buddy.
Okay, so you're saying that the angel
did know
before he asked.
It's not he doesn't know. He's
interceding telling God, "Enough." What
kind of angel has this influence to make
God turn towards Jerusalem with
compassion?
Read it, 12 to 14.
What did God do? He answered the angel
favorably and showed compassion to
Zachariah. Why? Cuz the angel
told him to.
But we jumped from Zachariah 1
when we're not finished this. See what
you're doing? I'm keeping up.
>> go back. Let's go back. Okay, so that
actually proved that angel is so
majestic he can get what he wants and
make God do what he wants and that's
Jesus.
We're going to get there.
In Zechariah 3:1-2, let's come back to
the point. There's a reason why verse
one begins by saying who Zechariah saw,
a reason you ignored.
Why did he mention not Hashem but the
angel of Hashem?
Right, so I'm just trying to
I'm just trying to to understand and I
to understand what you're trying to say
here. So
the who showed the vision to Joshua? Was
the angel? Was God? Is God is the angel?
I'm trying to understand. angel on
earth, they accompany each other, sent
to minister to Zechariah, is allowing
him to see the angel of Hashem. He's
allowing to see Joshua. He's allowing
him to see
That's what the angel's doing cuz there
are a whole host of entities in
Zechariah. One is an accompanying angel
that's working with Zechariah. Then he
sees the angel of Hashem who's not a
creature.
And the one he showed me, it's talking
about the accompanying angel who's
assigned to Zechariah to allow him to
have visions of the angel of Hashem and
other things. And we'll get to that. But
what I want
>> sorry. I hear what you're saying. Now I
just want one clarification. So the
angel that's on earth with Zechariah, is
he the same angel that's in the vision?
There's more than one angel that's in
Zechariah. The one who accompanies him
is not the angel of Hashem whom we claim
to be God.
Oh, so he's not the one. He's
Even in Zechariah 1, when he sees the
man in the myrtle trees, he's different
from other angels that also appear. It's
a whole group of entities that are
showing up in the first several
chapters. So you're going to have to
read carefully and distinguish, is this
angel simply a created servant
accompanying Zechariah or is he
announcing the angel of Hashem?
I hear. So so yeah, you're the expert.
I'm not trying to to do anything.
Yeah, I'm just trying to understand. So
the the angel in chapter 1 verse 12, it
says the angel of the Lord, right? So,
and also in chapter 3, which we were
talking about now, it's also angel of
the Lord. So, Yeah, it's one and the
same.
And also
>> So, are they the same angel? Yes, it's
uh we'll get there. Okay.
>> Because we didn't even get to 3 and 4.
We didn't even finish verse 2. So, I had
to keep jumping with you. Right, cuz I'm
trying to understand that. Yeah. Yeah,
I'm trying to understand because if he's
on earth, is he in the vision at the
same time?
My brother,
you mean the angel of Hashem Yeah.
>> cannot appear on earth and in heaven?
I'm asking. Do you claim he could? No,
I'm not saying he couldn't.
>> on earth.
He can appear on earth and in the next
scene, he can show himself in heaven.
Okay.
Because my question to you is, where is
this taking place?
Where is he seeing Joshua? Where is he
seeing Hasatan? When Hasatan comes,
where does he come to bring an
accusation? On earth or does he go to
heaven? It's a vision, vision. So, it's
not on earth, it's somewhere, not on
earth. I don't know where, but it's a
vision.
>> Even though Job 1 and 2, which you went
to, shows that Hasatan went to Hashem in
heaven, where the angels were.
Job 1 and 2, remember that? Verse 6, it
says, "There is a day in which the
angels or it's the sons of God,
Bnei Ha Elohim, which are angels,
appeared before Hashem and Satan was in
their midst. That's obviously heaven.
And what did he come to bring accusation
against Job, like he's doing here.
So, the vision
has to be heaven because Hasatan only
appears in heaven to bring accusations,
my friend.
Okay, now, let's get back to Zechariah
2. Oh, he left.
Did he leave?
I'm talking to myself?
Come on back, dude. We're not done, man.
Why did he leave?